but first our top story this hour the
dangerous and deadly heat baking nearly
half the nation tens of millions of
people are enduring record-setting high
temperatures this weekend add to that
the very high humidity that'll make the
heat index feel like more than a hundred
degrees well over 100 degrees here in
New York and some other major cities the
heat wave is already blamed for at least
six deaths
Nataly brand is in washington d.c
Natalie good morning good morning Kevin
we can feel the temperatures climbing
there's already a noticeable difference
between now and last hour all morning
we've watched locals and visitors stay
close to the fountain here at the World
War Two memorial even dip their feet
inside people want to be outside
enjoying their Saturday but city leaders
across the East Coast are warning this
heat can be dangerous even potentially
life-threatening the nation's capitol
joined dozens of cities in declaring a
weather-related emergency ahead of
potentially record-breaking temperatures
expected throughout the weekend this is
going to be one of the most severe heat
events that we've had in the last
several years dr. Christopher Rodriguez
is the director of the DC Homeland
Security and Emergency Management Agency
he says officials will be monitoring the
dangerous temperatures from this
Emergency Operations Center in
Washington DC cities in the Midwest are
also preparing for extreme heat but the
East Coast is expected to take the brunt
of it temperatures are expected to range
from the mid 90s to the triple digits
with the heat index making it feel
closer to 115 degrees I think the heat
we could feel if the humidity is Mel
New York City subway riders also felt
like they were melting thousands of
passengers were left stranded on
platforms and in trains yesterday due to
a major infrastructure malfunction that
halted six subway lines not just an
inconvenience but a health hazard
especially as it gets later into the day
and the afternoon again I want to stress
those symptoms of heat illness headache
dizziness nausea fatigue heavy sweating
or lack of sweating remember with this
high humidity it is more difficult for
our bodies to regulate temperature and
cool off Michelle good points to let us
know about Natalie thank you